is
[Music]
[Music]
so
did you sleep well
i did did you grow a mustache i did
do you like it i guess it's just a
little weird weird well you have me
chained up in your basement and i told
you the other day i was gonna grow a
mustache and then you come down here and
you have a mustache whatever you didn't
invent mustaches whatever man you're
copying me i'm not could i just please
have some of my patriots supply oatmeal
see
we're so alike
we finish each other's sentences ugh
everybody loves my patriot supply
especially the
[Music]
see
we're like brothers
[Music]
hey
maybe next tuesday do you think i could
go to the bathroom alone how about this
i won't hold it
i'll just watch
thank you
i'm gonna hang out with my friend gerald
until then
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
jennifer
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
you know i just can't help it let's just
get right into it uh hey guess who's
going bankrupt
so
oh
people listening on audio you have to go
over to you youtube or rumble equal pay
deal and soccer oh boy
[Laughter]
so glad
glad to be with you so you're going to
reduce the men's pay that's what's
happening yeah exactly or performance
yeah uh glad to be with you we have so
much to get you today look one thing i
want to talk about today and i just need
to let you know if we get removed and
i'm not just saying today
be talking about the election just you
know freeest fairest election of all
time i don't buy it
comment me youtube so if we get uh
removed or we don't tell you that we are
doing uh or not doing a show i should
say we're doing it every monday through
thursday 10 a.m eastern rumble and mug
club where today we're going to do an
extra 45 minutes on uh stuff that we
can't talk about here that's true and
something that you love near and dear
well it's important to note look there's
a narrative now that's coming crumbling
down and i think people and i hate to
use that term because everyone in
political narrative like you know
catherine like a narrative that i stuck
my junk in my cousin's face well that's
not a narrative you did it
um
that people
it's required for you to not question
what's happening or what has happened
certainly with
myriad issues whether it's covet whether
it's the election and a sort of a fun
the foundation of that is that this is
the most popular former vice president
ever ever joe biden
we've gone through now there's been some
twitter analytics that show how many
followers of his are fake but when we
look at what's happened with youtube and
how they've actually changed the
algorithms the dislike buttons for him
once you remove that precept it all
comes crumbling down and there is no way
that this is the most popular president
of all time so let me you know comment
you comment below do you buy
do the
what they tally it up to now 142 million
votes that he got i think maybe 150. do
you buy that every single one of those
votes is
legitimate it's okay yes it's okay
youtube hit that button it's okay
i dare you all right we'll be talking
about that but first gerald a how are
you sir i am well how are you my neck is
just i'm not doing that yeah yeah it's
just recurring yeah and the
chiropractors are mad at us from two
days ago when we you know pointed out
the truth wait you tried to go see one
and they wouldn't crack your neck well i
try to see one through a scope uh and
then uh
he waved no idea what that means it was
more of a flail
help
saw the red dot yeah
you know you can follow him on twitter
at landau dave he's going to be uh may
this this weekend the 27th 28th at big
al's in emily minnesota dave landau how
are you next weekend sorry yeah you're
all good ahoy how about you i didn't i
forgot the date that's right you're fine
i forgot what today's date was i
remembered your date i don't know dates
yeah yeah well but big out stuff big ale
is a good big yeah he's still big he's
an actual person he's a big fan of the
show
good for you really good guy
that's bold putting your name on there
and it's big al and not being you know a
male strip club or a gay animal
sanctuary yes exactly
but he's actually a really great guy big
fan of the show
yeah we also have to amend we're going
to have to amend something that we
discussed yesterday regarding uh project
veritas and the honey potting that they
do
so we will admonish ourselves we have to
do a fact check we'll do that later
today but first
here is uh one of my favorite
clips of the week
ever actually not just this week of ever
of all time here's an amazon porch thief
that's a problem
i've had them mm-hmm also by the way
stop sending me communion cups johnny
boy i have gotten the wrong package to
my house so many times and it's it's 4
000 little communion cups it's every
catholic in america trying to get you to
convert no no it's clearly a church that
has a similar address and i just i don't
know where to i tried to return it they
won't let me return it so amazon you
know get get your crap together get your
crap together and then
you used to just share yeah exactly from
the from the holy grail guys right yeah
yeah there's a herpes epidemic
so this amazon porch thief
father o'malley naughty boy
he runs into the brick wall that is a
usmc veteran uh and by the way it means
that marine hmm
[Laughter]
i wasn't trying to steal it
[Laughter]
he's
[Laughter]
and lays on the man's balcony who was
just trying to rob in a puddle of his
own feces
ah damn i just gonna rest oh i [ __ ]
myself you got a wet wife oh [ __ ] is
this box got a modium in it
i love that it's the best get my ass to
pimp yo
bismuth best use of a ring doorbell ever
do you think the man is going to help
you who you just tried to rob yeah but
you said you weren't trying to rob yet
the only way
that's going to go off is if you try to
take the
if you have a mask on why
you're obviously there just to help
right you know that guy's robbed a bank
and just showed up to a teller with blue
dye like this money is defective i need
to return it yeah the blue jay goes off
uh-huh did you see what he did myself
oh that's brown dye that's that's what
that is yeah you gave it it was like it
was like that one i found it yeah
oh man he reached into his underwear and
pulled his hand up to smell it and said
i [ __ ] myself i don't think that's
necessary no it's not that's a choice at
that point well yeah but that's on
camera and like he wasn't gonna put it
on the internet
i think you can feel yes yes indeed i
have crapped my pants i don't need to
feel down there
it's to haunt him every day the rest of
his life from everyone he knows
do you think he's going to wear a diaper
now when he goes porch thieving oh
probably oh yeah i love that guy's
taunting oh oh yeah that's what you get
yeah a marine corps i love
[Laughter]
sense of entitlement to go back to the
porch that you were trying to rob to ask
for help and you live next door yeah
he's like i lived next door i wasn't
trying to see you i was trying to bring
the package back what did you learn is
robbing from the big bad wolf
let me in
not by the hell my chin and ginger
mother i didn't use the phone yeah in
case you didn't know who i was because
of the mask i live right next door and i
got [ __ ] in my pants
[Music]
it wasn't me though somebody's [ __ ]
my pants he lives extremely gonna have
to see each other every day yeah every
day
forever puts his head down in rocks
how's your pants
i noticed i noticed you you you tend to
only wear brown dickies now is that what
you do
that's a style choice right that's what
hey can you pick up this package for me
hey you got a job yet
hey man uh i want to make a man he's got
to get free just toss his mouth strap
i pooped again just throws a flashbang
on him he go bye yeah while he catches
it all of a sudden he just get hit with
bottle rockets
it's a roman candle
he owns that gun
totally
screw with him forever oh it's the best
i'm sorry i needed that okay everyone
should do that
even if it's your loved one who's coming
home and picking up the package yeah
that's what you get felicia yeah i told
you yell at your wife do it to old
incontinent uncle moe yes
by the way don't do that don't don't rig
your packages as much that's like way
less funny it's just oh my hip shattered
yeah oh sorry yeah you're gonna bleed
out on the porch yeah you like that i
did nothing to you
i was trying to help
it was labeled it was labeled with my
name in christmas rapture amazon told me
they gave it to you to give to me she
met a mucil
oh i'll keep you regular mother
oh gosh i hope there's a follow-up of
them you know just pulling up at night
so fun good evening sam all right he
smells his hand
he almost said that would you look at it
you didn't know yeah you're like is this
oh is that pudding yeah i'm just i'm
just disoriented
that's the only thing it could be sir
search blaming him you push it in my
pants
why would you do that what kind of
voodoo
that was a [ __ ] explosive oh geez
i heard about
i heard about these but i never seen it
i want to see a slow-mo of him when he
grabs the package and goes flying off
the board that's some duty might that
you got in there that's my fault
it's a damn shitty
all right
that's good stuff okay i'm sorry we're
children
sorry no we're not and neither is that
guy and it's hilarious
we just need more of this i hope just
that there are a bunch of people who
start doing this in new york city well
and i think the guy's fine i don't think
it was like he didn't get shot or
anything i wouldn't care well
yeah it doesn't matter to me no at a
certain point like there used to be a
time in society when people were only
net drains where all they would do is
steal or harm and you're like i'm sorry
we're just we're just gonna have to
execute you it wasn't just for the
offensive murder it's like if you're
doing nothing but taking and harming you
were you were excommunicated from the
group there you go yeah i'm sure
everybody here has had an amazon package
stolen i've had many yep
which really when you think about it
that's that could be a lot of work for
very little payoff you don't know what
growth package is no no you get home and
you're like oh good vitamins right for
women yeah
or covid tests like in l.a but sometimes
baby formula oh my scalp
yeah you just got 10 grand
oh that's old that's old price gouger
tie yeah you can get your formula from
him he's got a corner on simelac
it doesn't smell the best but you know
good for upset stomachs
all right so i do that because we're
going to get something a little bit a
little bit heavier here uh but uh you
remember the guy jaden jaden hayden
i know it sounds like a made up name but
it's not rhyme
uh he was the man who was on video this
is another example of why we love seeing
what you just saw because of the catch
and release that you see with violent
criminals that you see with the worst
among us it's destroyed cities and this
namely happens in leftist cities so
jaden hayden was the man uh who was on
video and i warned you that this next
unlike the previous clip which was
hysterical
and fun for the whole family it was a
feel-good story of the year this is
pretty rough i'm going to show it really
short but this is the guy who beat up an
elderly man in the old folks home in
michigan let me refresh your memory and
i'll i'll keep it as short as i can it
was in westland yeah
yeah
all right okay people get the point so
um in case you don't remember that video
goes on for a minute and a half was not
the only video of that kind because of
policy that was taking place in michigan
again under the guise of covet all of
your your freedoms and basic social
boundaries were removed where they were
putting young p young people who tested
positive for covet into old folks homes
yeah that was not a worker i personally
thought that was somebody who worked
there was pissed off beating nope that
was somebody put in his room and that
old man went on to uh to die that's
killing months later yeah start himself
so after the time of the arrest that uh
that man jayden his father did come out
and to his father's credit and he even
said that his son had mental problems he
said it should have never happened
because he should have never been put in
that environment i just don't want
people to think that he's this vicious
individual he's got mental issues well
look he does have mental issues and he's
a vicious individual and um the guy the
old man uh died two months after the
beating yeah now here's the thing what
happened is it can be true yeah
after the uh
uh well he was arrested in april he was
just found this is this is quote
incompetent to go to trial
because he was diagnosed with autism and
schizophrenia uh and uh so
that's it
yeah so just back on the street right
yeah yep oh you back out that's oh
that's the best place for him yeah so
wait a minute so can he has
schizophrenia mm-hmm and so we're just
like yeah put him back on the street
yeah well he's incompetent to uh to just
to go through a trial can we can we it's
like well so he's comp so but he's
competent for society right like he
can't just say the words not guilty in a
plea because he's so out of his mind
let's send him back out in the street no
no he's going to be a poll worker yes
yeah he's going to make sure the
election is going to be the 201st mule
yes he's doing security at an old folks
home in florida right
so this is again like i've talked about
it was because whitmer decided this is
what happened young people with coveted
were sent into nursing homes you know
people talk about how it's spread like
wild wildfire through nursing homes and
i understand that because old people
were more susceptible we get it yeah but
it wasn't that wasn't the only thing
that was happening they were sending
young people with coven saying where do
we put them uh nursing homes
and by the way this is something that we
did a rally where some media tried to
claim it was like some kind of a
supremacy rally or they tried to claim
that they were terrorists then they
tried to say actually it was nothing
there were only 300 people when there
were thousands of people on the state
lawn and you can still by the way send
your foia request uh to governor whitmer
at lightweight.com
whitmer death toll she's never released
the actual numbers we know that it's
much much higher than what she's
admitted yeah well yeah well i mean a
lot of people died of covid and blows to
the head so in fairness it wasn't all
coveted it wasn't all coping yeah yeah
well not even kidding sending coveted
paper into a nursing home was a bad
enough idea obviously it happened in new
york it happened in michigan it happened
other places too
but sending a young person into it's
like these are the most vulnerable
people both for violence and for
something like covet what the hell we
had been saying from the beginning you
need to protect the vulnerable yeah
namely the elderly the immune
compromised and then let it run its
course with society not lock everyone
else down they did the exact opposite
now i want to really be clear about
something i talked about this with nancy
pelosi people use the lazy argument oh
you're a hypocrite oh someone governor
whitmer is a hypocrite nancy it's not
that they're a hypocrite everyone is a
hypocrite if you have any kind of
standards you're a hypocrite okay i'm a
hypocrite gerald's a hypocrite dave's
everyone here is a hypocrite it's not
that someone is hypocritical
it's when they are demanding rules of
you that they don't believe so governor
whitmer the small action that told you
that was true was when she locked down
the state and she was out with 12 people
at a pizza parlor
with no mask on that told you not that
she was a hypocrite but that she wasn't
actually scared of cobit when she was
saying we need to lock down the economy
because we need to protect people and
sending young people with covid into old
folks homes it's not that she's
hypocritical it's that she doesn't
actually care about saving people she
doesn't buy what she's selling you
that's the issue and that's what is
destroying our country right now
it's not that she doesn't care about
saving people she's an accomplice to
murder at that point yep in my opinion
and she has a good point in calling
places and saying i'd like to get my
boat in the water if that's okay and
then he's like what if i said tell you
i'm the governor's uh husband he's like
well then i would tell you you're never
allowed to put your boat in the water at
my doctor i would like to apologize for
your boat burning tomorrow yeah oh
you're the one with the glass bottom
boat no no oh sorry it's just a hole
yeah sorry about that that's our bed but
yeah she you're absolutely right these
are people who they use power that's not
hypocrisy
right you know what happens to you dave
if you're negligent and it leads to the
death of somebody else oh you go to
prison potentially you're in jail yeah
right so as you said governor whitmer
you were pretty negligent here this
wasn't like far off stuff that you had
to go on what in my crystal ball should
i do with people who have covet that are
27 years old that have mental problems
yeah we we could have figured that out
pretty easily right that's not negligent
well two things first off admonished
gerald hit that admonish button because
whitmer does not use a crystal ball she
used the mirror mirror on the wall
we want to make sure we get that right
also
the guy who we just showed you the
marine who rigged his amazon package he
does that in the wrong state he's the
one arrested so if people like this
criminal back on the streets you have
repeat violent offenders back on the
streets and then people who protect
their own house and home are the ones
who are arrested keep in mind this is
the same party that wants to vilify
you for having a gun in your house to
protect yourself it's the inconsistency
which can the inconsistency of their
policies consistently leads to to the
death of more law-abiding citizens to
the harm of more law-abiding
citizens citizens yes
my my neck thing is messing up my abs do
you have a secret no i ate a bunch of uh
like acidic food and you get like all
those bumps on your tongue so i'm
sitting there trying to talk like this
you know what could make that that
marine corps thing better like that he
could like do a glitter bomb as well
like just just to rub it in like just
all over it i [ __ ] myself and i look gay
oh man this is bad
why didn't you watch you put the glitter
in there
i have a like yeah
oh no i see myself and i look gay this
is almost like a cake and he just starts
playing over the speakers the game made
him all just shares do you believe in
love let me in they're coming over come
on realize his mouth is glued oh no
can i use your water
hose a bunch of gay guys like 28 dicks
later oh damn
[Laughter]
help help i smell it i'm coming to
glitter they're playing [ __ ] i'm being
chased what was in that package astro
glide
[Laughter]
why did you buy ball gags
[Laughter]
all right but yeah that that's uh we
need more uh violent schizophrenics on
the streets in detroit i've always said
that we're reaching that point where a
lot of people don't realize this you
know you had the soft on crime era and
then you had these heroes in film like
dirty harry like charles bronson right
death wish where the vigilante genre was
something that was cathartic for
americans because they felt helpless and
you saw that in new york city with uh
bernie bernie goetz yeah
um
i think there's a big disconnect between
the democratic party and again law
abiding citizens who are seeing their
neighborhoods being destroyed and feel
as though they're helpless and they're
seeing policies coming down the pike
like disarming them like more catch and
release
like basically some kinds of subsidies i
mean we can add all these up to
encourage people to not work which we
know does not make for a productive law
abiding society and there's a real
disconnect between the elites who are
not affected
and you and that's why you have to rig
your porch with you know glitter bomb
and then you see politicians actively
stoking this violence like going out and
participating in these protests that
burn down cities saying that we'll have
to be in the streets like right before
george floyd's verdict was read like if
if it doesn't come back the right way
we're burning it down basically like
that
with roe v wade it's not you just you're
not protected it's they're actively
encouraging the thing that is costing
you and your community right
every single and you're being told that
it's virtuous by the people that are
supposed to protect you right who create
the laws
who do you think would get more trouble
the people protesting let's say at brett
kavanaugh's house i know they're on
public property but let's say that they
went up to the porch and they get you
know hit within like an acme spring that
sends them back to the capitol of course
it would be a national story about how
kavanaugh would be in trouble yeah of
course he was accused of gang rape which
we know is complete we know for a an un
this is not a it's not up for debate
it's not there's no conversation about
it it has been proven verifiably but
there was no gang rape that i'd ever
taken but you still have some people who
believe it oh of course all right
here's a story that uh just happened uh
which is i guess somewhat believable but
uh
somewhat i don't know it's a real story
a three-month-old giraffe was
successfully rehabilitated with an
orthotic
leg brace treatment
i don't agree with you guys on this one
i think it's very exciting if you're a
giraffe and your legs don't work come on
what do you do your ticket's been
punched
next with a neck brace i mean come on
it's like you only have two things long
legs and a neck
what do you drop him in the serengeti
and just let nature take its course yes
if nature's kind they'll take him in as
one of their own but nature isn't it's a
cruel place so they'll eat him but
humans can be kind and they built legs
yes exactly braces all you do is stand
tall and you can't even do that actually
he was born with legs they were blown
off trying to steal an amazon practice
well jeffrey's fallen under a hard time
toys r us business when it went down
in its wake don't get me start on their
rival gang the kbs now in sad animal
news actually uh spider the chupacabra
was decapitated in a gang land attack uh
at the bronx zoo oh yeah oh
poor guy yeah who runs by the way who
who who runs the uh the bronx zoo cartel
i believe it's el chimpo of cheese i
hear his drugs are great ape
it's terrible
i don't apologize for it but uh to the
chupacabre
you know you were taken from us too
young we are sorry
much love
[Music]
[Music]
i think it's fair i think we made our
point we
it's a proper tribute yeah hey by the
way speaking of points uh this i would
you saw that commercial for my patriot
supply go to prep with crowder.com you
get 150
off on a three-month emergency food
supply here's the thing you know i've
worked with them before in the past the
prep with crowder.com patriot supply um
guys can you send me some more of the
oatmeal i've asked you for it and i
don't know what interns you have working
there if it's like a thing where you
guys are just pissing me off refusing to
send the oatmeal it's better than the
oatmeal you get at the store with
holding oatmeal they're withholding
oatmeal so i love and pudding and
pudding you like the potato love the
sponsor prep with crowder.com you get
150 off but i don't like that they have
not sent me
more oatmeal buckets of oatmeal yeah
it's one of those things you don't need
to be a doomsday theorist i mean just
look at the guy stealing amazon packages
look at that guy right now i just was
let out he was beating up an old old
dude this is where we are in this
country at this point i lived through
the ice dorm in montreal you just need
to have a supply of food and you need to
have some water some way to heat it
people used to say that we were a
conspiracy theorist if you're like oh
you're gonna need a prep yeah i'm not
talking about you know uh red dawn i'm
just talking about making sure that i
don't starve in the first thirty the
original red dot not the remake yeah at
all right no but what about just supply
chain issues we've seen that with name
the product yeah and it's happened so
yeah that's helpful unfortunately
there's no baby formula in here well you
can't eat the chupacabra's head right
very i mean that's going to go it can
it's just sanui it's kind of gamey so
fast yeah all right hey this is another
segment that we uh we're going to hit
here because he's more passionate about
it it's time
for gerald to take the reins he knows
things
that is that the best we can do really
yeah it is yes we're going to keep that
stinger so gerald you want to you want
to uh educate our audience i will right
so this black lives matter stuff and by
the way you guys can all comment we'll
take your chats on how how well you
think gerald's doing with us go ahead
are you just going to drink a 40 while
i'm talking about that is there a
sponsor brought to you by a bum that
bought you a drink in the 90s yeah can
you at least get a brown paper sponsor
thank you well recently uh recently
there was some tax filings that revealed
uh some really interesting ways to spend
money for the charity the charity that
was set up for black lives matter and uh
they had 90 million
dollars in donations received in 2020
alone and i think it'll be interesting
for people to see how they spend it so
we had 190 million dollars 90 million
dollars for blm some people say that's a
lot of money so one month i believe they
say that's a lot of cheddar
you know that's a fair point one point
eight million
companies owned by the founders
relatives so here's here and i'm going
to say paid you understand what i mean
by paid right basically they were giving
money given money patrice color's
brother paul was paid 840 000
for security services dollars eight
hundred forty keep my ass safe right
don't wanna poop
patrice's baby daddy was paid nine
hundred and seventy thousand dollars get
this to help produce live events and
creative services because that's
detailed enough for us to understand
that this is totally legitimate i am a
creative
serving
person by the way i need you to
understand something too did you hear
those dollar amounts that i just gave
out yes and i told you that these
donations were in 2020 this is when they
got the money so this is 2022 the
beginning this is over a very short
period of time that they were paid this
much money i don't think that you could
pay the highest charging company that
promotes events
that much money in that short of a
period of time
banners you could if it was unmarked 20s
i don't i don't think that that's true
too no this is important for people to
know it's entirely been a scam from the
beginning it is absolutely insane we
talked about the homes that she
purchased in another story we had done
quite a while back but now we're looking
at the money and she just basically gave
away to relatives we just put her in a
home you'd be like yeah creative
services what did you know
i came up with like paintings of blm oh
good this is fun you and hunter biden
can go on a like painting tour i guess
yeah all right so another asset that
they have is actually stock so they had
42 million dollars another asset 6
million dollars in a compound invested
for studio city it's a house basically
that she lives in saying no no no it's
going to be for black artists and people
to come in yes and then 32 million
dollars in stocks now here's why they
have that's how i produce my mixtapes
they have the stocks to make sure that
they can continue to provide
for future generations of blm activists
to come in and have money in the charity
like what if you buy the wrong stocks
like what if markets going down right
now how's that 32 million dollars doing
well how is she gonna afford her
battered scam artist shelter it was all
game stop at its highest point
no that's exactly right she hedged it
with amc no no no no no but then it was
mostly in doge yeah so they they love
that they love the dogs
it was a bad idea but hold on here's so
here's yeah theory silver line right
tuesday they came out uh on their
website and they launched the
transparency center oh wow maybe a
little too too little too late on here
you want me to read the quote
no but you got read the quote in a good
voice give me like uh give me a voice
yeah you mean something that might sound
like black lives matter or morgan
freeman or al sharpton i don't know if
you take your pick i'd almost do morgan
freeman make it more gentlemanly there
you go i can do the i can do the the
black people white person voice so i
don't get in trouble
okay that's fine the misinformation from
the right wing about our finances is
very much about what happens when black
people are financially autonomous from
white supremacists ah there is a
long-standing legacy of mistrust and
doubt about how black people spend their
money don't know why people sound like
that [ __ ]
so you're you're truth center right to
make sure that everybody knows that
you're being transparent and honest is
basically saying white people are racist
and like to tell black people how to
spend their money okay let's just take
this away anybody who pays relatives to
do those things for them security
services and the guy gets almost a
million dollars the other person sets up
events for you and does creative
services and gets
nearer a million dollars than the other
person you are paying yes people are
going to do that it's called being a
business you're a charity which means
you have to tell your donors how you
spend your money and they get to say
whether they like that or not sorry real
world this just applies the same kind of
outrage you did to joel osteen or
haggard and that kind of stuff that's
absolutely right any church
tammy faye baker just apply the same
standard look you're fleecing people
also again it's not that it's
hypocritical that this person i think
the house was three million i can't
remember from a story before it's three
or four million dollars yeah it's not
that that's the critical homes it's that
you don't believe it you don't believe
that there's systemic racism and
oppression because you use that system
to fleece the so-called oppressors six
million dollar house six million dollars
six well six million
six in this one she's got other houses
that she bought the story came out i
think it was a daily mail that broke it
or something like that that she had
other homes in other places that doesn't
even include this one that we mentioned
that's six million here well i got a six
million dollar house i i gotta have a
mountain imaginable
i like to stand on them like ski i don't
think that that's true at all
so of course of course the pivot is
racism of course they're missing so
here's the funny part too they're
misrepresenting our financials you know
they call it white rich yeah i mean by
posting your financials we're
misrepresenting your financials this is
an epidemic of what we call nouveau
black
yes so
money yes just in case you're thinking
of donating to blm don't yeah don't
donate to black lives matter look it's a
scam we always knew it was a scam and
what will happen is the media will move
on not acknowledge the scam the media
right of course what happened is they
whipped you all up into a frenzy you
rioted you believe some stories that
weren't true and now the money's been
given away and they're just not going to
cover their screw-ups that's what it's
not the lies that you hear blatantly
it's the stories that they never choose
to cover
and that's what's going to happen well
okay thank you you guys can comment
below as to how you like you know gerald
bringing in these segments because he is
he's a he's a smart dude this has been
gerald knows things
guys i'm gay
fabulous i i feel like they did that in
like 10 like we do good work here yeah
no that's that is good almost seems
intentional good job good job even
brennan almost i don't know why you kept
saying that to the mic though yeah i
know it was weird yeah it was weird that
when we gave him the lines
weird just believable he just refused to
say them i hate all of you yeah well you
know what it's wrong to hate
so let's get on here to uh former vice
president biden yes
now the premise needs to be set up and
we were just talking about whitmer we
okay you know what let's just say this
with michigan michigan people think
because the vote gap was so wide that
there's no way there could have been
some some uh untoward activity
absolutely we know michigan none of it
added up whatsoever
yeah i don't agree with it i was going
to say
most of the people in michigan i know
don't think it ended up because yeah
they said that wayne county had gone for
trump and then there was like a cooler
of ballots and then they were covering
up windows it seemed fishy at best yeah
at 3 30 in the morning it was 100
something thousand dollars here's here's
the problem is he was donald trump was
performing so much better in urban areas
just like he he won all the bellwether
counties except for one he was out
performing his previous performance with
blacks with latinos with every
demographic and then his stronger areas
these suburban areas came back in a race
sometimes 95 98 percent for biden and
michigan would say well hold on that's
because their melon votes they were
going to be democrats but you also said
that the majority of people were male in
voting so you can't have just democrats
it didn't add up but because it was such
a wide gap because of the corruption in
michigan anyone who lives there knows
exactly what i'm talking about they just
say well there's no way that this could
have been uh this could have anything
but the freest and fairest election
because uh it's 160 000 whatever votes
as opposed to arizona where it's a much
smaller gap right exactly they just make
the lie so egregious that it's they
assume people won't question it whereas
i think michigan is the most blatant
example of something not adding up there
you go and you can go to our previous
episodes where dave was sent to like
nine addresses that didn't actually
exist yeah it was weird it was 100 of
them yes
we thought at least one might exist
no just by the way is this the same
michigan that had to overturn a local
election because they got the results
wrong and told somebody they lost and
then had to tell the other person that
they actually yes oh
but free and fair and absolutely
accurate right got it now here's the
thing so they want you to believe
nationally they don't want anyone to
question
even though by the way the current uh
press secretary said that the 2016
election was stolen so
oh so they don't want you to even
question what's happening when these are
statistical anomalies that occur nowhere
else in nature and it's predicated on
the idea that former vice president joe
biden is the most popular president ever
and of course they say well it wasn't
necessarily a vote for biden it was a
vote against trump it still doesn't make
sense and we'll go through the numbers
to show you why that's obviously been
plumped up and it's not some grand
conspiracy it only it only requires five
people to lie requires p
five heads of companies
to lie and we'll i'll present to you how
that's happening
verified all references available at a
lot of credit.com and right now of
course uh former vice president is he's
doing such a bang-up job that uh elon
musk even took time uh out of his day to
to praise the former vp's performance
but it's not as if biden has flipped the
script and said okay we're going to go
180 degrees in the other direction he's
kind of kept it the same
which has been really surprising
actually man it's hard to tell what bite
is doing if we told frank um
like
i feel like it's weak at bernie's
the the real president is whoever
controls the teleprompter the path to
power is the path to the teleprompter
you know i do feel like like if somebody
would accidentally lead on the lean on
the teleprompter it's going to be like
anchorman it's going to be like qqq
asdf123 you know type of thing
[Music]
i mean
in fairness to biden he he hasn't been
napping as much as he needs to but
it's just it's hard hard job
things that are getting done you know
now that's a little harsh i yeah it was
it was rough especially because it's not
like biden has said anything that
crazy
look
i know you got to be frustrated
i know
i can taste it
all right maybe elon was just harsh
enough yeah it's like i know
you're all burning toast i can smell it
i like it i know i know i can try to
steal a package i can take
i know pennies i can taste this
i smell the poop
on myself here's the thing and dave you
know this there's real value in seeing
you know elon musk saying that and an
entire audience laughing that's a
guttural reaction that they can't
control again when someone else is not
controlling what it is that you see or
hear people instinctively laugh because
they know it's true
yes of course that's the beauty of
comedy that's why they're going after
comedians it's people don't like you
can't control laughing it's just it's an
involuntary response and you see it
there in real time well this is what
comedians were saying two years ago yeah
well and that's not even something that
he didn't even say funny line he just
said we don't really know what he's
doing and it's so bad and it's so
obvious that people were like yeah oh
god we're all gonna die by the way that
guy that guy literally made the joke
that uh kat williams's recent special
where he actually they bring out this
weekend that bernie's mother he makes
that exact joke yeah yeah i like that so
maybe he watched the summit
yeah just added a few mf's and n words
you can't quote most of that now that's
mine i patent that [ __ ]
everybody truth that everybody's been
calling him a dead guy that's propped up
now for years
well he looks like it
no he does sounds like it looks like
fire marshall bill yes that's the creepy
part when you see that meme and i'm like
that
on it really is yep it's pretty rough
even at the summit i should say elon uh
had uh oh that's right he said this
about uh about his voting pattern this
is also pretty important and um you know
the the reality is uh that twitter at
this point you know has a very far-left
bias um and i would class to myself as
as a moderate and you know neither the
republican or nor democrat um and in
fact uh i have voted vote overwhelmingly
for democrats uh historically
overwhelmingly like i'm not sure
i might never have voted for a
republican just to be clear right now
now this election i would
come on man
welcome to the tent well i hope i hope
this isn't just a selfish motive you
know what i mean right i hope he's not
just trying to
find out what look he's benefitted from
america yeah yeah he's benefited from
subsidies he's benefited from the green
movement that being said he's also done
a lot to serve consumers and to advance
technology so he's not perfect i'm just
hoping that he continues along down this
trail in 10 years from now he's not
saying i i also still have never voted
for republicans because then
you're stupid
now it's not just elon musk and i'm not
in the business of defending
billionaires you know how much i dislike
jeff bezos i would love to see jeff
bezos get amazon package uh bombed with
his penis rocket yes that would be
really weird
so um he got in he criticized biden for
conflating you know we talked about
inflation taxes
and raising them and how that would
actually fight inflation so bezos went
after
biden and uh this is what he said he
said it doesn't require a huge leap to
figure out why one of the wealthiest
individuals on the earth opposes an
economic agenda for the middle class oh
sorry that's a q that's a quote uh from
the white house
because bezos said uh i should have read
the other quote first my apologies we
have this is overlay e from twitter jeff
bezos and the references are available
at loudoutwithcredit.com
he said look a squirrel this is the
white house statements about my recent
tweets they understandably want to muddy
the topic they know inflation hurts the
neediest the most but unions aren't
causing inflation and neither are
wealthy people remember the
administration tried their best to add
another 3.5 trillion to federal spending
they failed but if they had succeeded
inflation would be even higher than it
is today and inflation today is at a
40-year high look this is something and
i'm not i'm not in the business of
defending jeff bezos and billionaires
but keep in mind all of these people
have consistently supported democrats
yes to be clear absolutely they
typically don't go after the white house
so the white house was responding that
first thing was their response to bezos
tweeting earlier and then he's like and
he responded to that response yeah
they're distracting you from what's
really going on here because their plan
won't fight inflation we've talked about
this before billionaires tend to benefit
from administration policies that are
contracting the economy right because
they are the ones that can handle the
issues they can handle the slumps they
can also handle all of the regulations
the mom and pop shops can't they go out
of business they have more market share
they're fine you've got billionaires now
poking the bear that typically don't
poke the bear right and that has to show
you like that is how bad things are they
don't care at this point right they know
they're doing a crappy job put it this
way let's say
they put an extra 50 cent tax on coffee
okay just in a hypothetical situation
who do you think's affected more
your local coffee roaster shop that only
has one place or starbucks
because even if starbucks has one
shutdown guess what they can withstand
it and then they're going to be the only
ones left standing right that's what
happens that's why these big that's why
big banks that's why big airlines that's
why health care companies health
insurance companies they're just betting
on who they think will allow them to
withstand the dip for as long as
possible it's harder for you because you
don't have a never-ending supply not
only of billions of dollars but federal
funds like a lot of these companies well
no faint outrage oh no don't do that
it'll kill the industry can't do that
okay okay fine we're here still yeah
exactly that's totally fine so you think
you think joe biden you know um some of
you may think he doesn't know how to
deal with inflation well here's the
thing i will say that um i don't think
he clearly doesn't
and that's because he has proven that he
doesn't through his own words let's
listen to former vice president joe
biden
back then by back then i mean anywhere
from a year ago to like last week
most of the price increases we've seen
are were expected and expected to be
temporary i don't know anybody including
larry summers who's a friend of mine
yeah who's worried about inflation talk
of inflation
the overwhelming consensus is going to
pop up a little bit and then go back
down
no one's talking about bro this great
great you know it's highly unlikely
that's going to be long-term inflation
that's going to get out of hand there's
nobody suggesting there's nonsense
inflation on the way by the way really
quickly i just want to point out before
i get to what he's saying now when you
hear someone on the left make the
argument from consensus right away you
need to start doing some research
because truth is not always governed by
consensus for example you can have a
consensus of economists who say that
actually inflation is a good thing
remember when joe biden was arguing that
you can have a consensus like they say
97 of scientists which is horse crap
about uh climate change that there's a
consensus on it well hold on science
isn't governed by consensus it's not
determined by consensus it's determined
by truth the same thing
for the economy doesn't at this point we
don't need a bunch of speculators we
don't need a bunch of ivory tower
economists telling us what they think is
going to happen they were wrong before
and we are living it you need to look at
the statistics you need to look at the
data and how inflation has affected
goods and services so when they argue
from the general consensus is
yeah that doesn't that's not an argument
you're simply saying these people told
me this so i'm going to repeat it
because you're not willing to put your
skin in the game and make an argument
what's the inflation rate joe
what's the price of beef joe what's the
price of gas joe what's the price of
everything joe uh consensus no no no
we're not going to let you get out with
that one we did that with climate change
for years and look where we are
consensus consensus consensus at one
point there were there was consensus to
put leeches on people to suck the demons
out of them until we found out that you
know
they had some like sickle cell whatever
it was leeches don't work in case you
don't know that now
so let's go
to what joe biden is saying now about
inflation with america's inflation
anxiety already in overdrive
what's happening just said blood
pressure's racing again this weekend the
average price jumped to 445 a gallon
that's an all-time high but beyond the
consensus
is even higher now others feel as though
they're running on fumes i've never used
the food banks before but now
i really
almost have to come i mean it's changed
very fast millions need help asap with
food prices up again both groceries and
dining out for sure airline tickets
soaring and most new cars come with one
option pay above sticker price oh wow
you're doing a great job joe bang up
john hey by the way it's something that
maybe people don't notice do you the
last three issues that they touched on
can you guys
name
a similarity a through line with those
they showed
airline tickets going up
gas they showed gas going ups food cars
food
yeah these are industries devoid of
regulations or bailout funds yeah right
no there aren't agricultural subsidies
they don't dump milk in fixed prices to
protect the farmer no no airlines have
received no bailouts we can't remember
any of the bailouts from the auto
industry right so where do you see
inflation
hitting people the worst and by the way
of course gas i don't know there's no
regulation in the oil industry right of
course this is an unregulated wild west
yeah again the industries and the
problem is these industries then affect
all of the others they've never had to
get it right
so when you have an industry like cars
yeah with the american car manufacturers
who deserve to go bankrupt because they
they created crappy cars that people
didn't want to buy they get bailed out
well guess what they've never corrected
their business model
and now we also add on top of that a
hurting economy well that makes
inflation worse when you look at
agricultural subsidies well they've
never gotten it right so we need to
protect the farmer because it's
unpredictable well guess what now you're
being subsidized by the government
you've never had to readjust your
business model you've never had to look
at your profits and losses and now we
have a bad economy and so it's even
worse you look at airlines how many
times have we bailed out airlines yeah
remember supposed to be temporary that
you were going to pay for checked bags
right
they never have to readjust their
business model so there's never a point
where the prices go down that's
something that people don't necessarily
understand a lot of inflation is because
the these prices keep going up because
they never have to get it right
right well it's a perverse incentive
because they know that the government
will bail them out and so they will make
increasingly risky bets until it happens
right you don't want that to happen
because that crashes the economy for
everybody but them right well yeah from
25 a bag to like 35 if you check two to
now it's more expensive if you check too
right and flights that were
seriously 200 a year ago
are 900
now right well that's why i decided to
check you as a bag dave well that's what
i gave you an oxygen bottle i mean come
on i go in a little puppy crate he does
the old yogi berra routine
here's the thing think about it this way
let's move forward a few years so the
airlines have been bailed out let's use
it as an example airlines sucked okay
couldn't get their business model right
american taxpayers bailed them out so
what happened did the tickets go down
did airlines become more competitive no
they don't need to because they're not
beholden to the markets the tickets go
up okay now the prices have gone up what
should usually happen is fewer people
are going to fly yes right and so the
airline goes oh my gosh we're losing
revenue we need to you know you know
what will happen the airlines will say
we're losing revenue we can't sustain
ourselves and then the government will
step in and bail them out so you never
have the recorrection and the dip you
just have a constant line of more money
more money more money more money more
money that doesn't happen anywhere else
it doesn't happen anywhere else in
business if the demand goes down you
better find a way to either cut the
prices create a more competitive product
or you're gone these industries have
never had to do that well and then
overlay unions in these industries yeah
right with the inability to change some
of these things because prices are going
down people aren't flying i'm sorry
prices going up people aren't flying
they can't right they have fixed costs
because of this well too big to fail
well too big it's going to fail we can't
because if the airline's closed yeah no
one else will step up and you know how
will people get around
teleportation i don't know
so i like that
i would like to do that too i just don't
want to end up like goldblum in the fly
i know i always think about that too you
like it to your destination hawaii and
you're just like
but you're in hawaii where's dave's on
the wall
don't complain
so here's the thing we obviously know
that billionaires don't like joe biden
uh we also know the middle class working
class doesn't really like joe biden um
but he does have a base
yeah somewhere right a base of the most
popular president ever ever yes history
i'm sorry that was a lie
so this just came out this is a newsweek
by the way
biden's twitter followers
turns out over half of them are fake
what
yeah this is from newsweek spark tarou's
tool this is a tool like an a tool that
actually i don't know runs an algorithm
to find out which accounts are fake yeah
the tool found that 49.3 of personal
accounts following the official
president united states twitter account
are fake followers based on an analysis
of a number of factors including
location issues default profile images
and new users um here's the thing
this should surprise nobody
if you've been following what we've been
discussing on the show because there
have been little chips uh
chips that have been sort of been
happening in big tech right they chip
away they chip away they chip away that
we've been
highlighting for a few years now yeah
this is just a new one where people go
oh this is relevant because of elon musk
talking about bots which by the way they
may have committed fraud if they lied to
him about the percentage of fake users
on twitter so there are a lot of
dynamics at play but it's not just
twitter um youtube we talked about this
they removed dislikes from jen saki's
first press
briefing there were so many yeah and
there was over a four hour span when we
covered this dislikes went from more
than ten thousand down to three thousand
oh my gosh and even even politifact
acknowledged this just so you know and
this is something i know pretty well
with youtube so we saw this happen right
there was a there was a discrepancy with
likes and dislikes
and then the dislikes were removed
independent creators like myself
we loved the dislike button yeah because
we go hey look at it look at this and
then look at trevor noah
right it shows what the market actually
wants versus you thrusting seth meyers
into someone's auto play for the
umpteenth time which nobody has asked
for in the history of ever i pay them to
do that to you right well you know what
well played defective that's a that's a
digital version of an exploding amazon
package
and i poop
so
with youtube politifact said oh it was
spam look that doesn't check out
obviously what would be spam is let's
say a press briefing or let's say some
kind of an address from former vice
president biden let's say it had 50 000
likes and then it jumped
all of a sudden in a way that was not
aligned with a pattern to 75 000 likes
that's where you could say someone is
going in that they're spam or even
what would be considered but not quite
denial of service tactics where a bunch
of people went in and spammed a dislike
yeah what i have never seen on youtube
is a like and dislike ratio and then it
changing yeah changing where it says no
no we're going to change likes are going
to go up and dislike dislikes never ever
go down that cannot be spam someone has
to manually go in and change that
someone said oh my gosh
this is comparing this to the trump
briefings comparing this to the trump
state of the union addresses we got a uh
uh uh boom and switch it and then when
they said that then when a bunch of
people said hey well a second you
switched it they said no no we didn't it
was spam but you know what it's not
gonna be a problem anymore because we're
just gonna get rid of the dislike button
yeah well i was gonna say did you do
that for the independent creators that
are conservative that had a
disproportionate amount of spam for
dislikes because if it's happening to
the white house certainly it's happening
to other people yes you did it across
the board right or did you just do it
for the white house right yeah just like
they want to do it for big tech wants to
be in bed with big companies yeah
youtube wants to be in bed with cnn and
msnbc because they have more advertising
dollars keep in mind nbc
gets fake favorite favoritism in the
algorithms because they spend
i don't know how many millions of
dollars in advertising on youtube and
independent content creators can't so
they're on both sides of that coin and
of course half of their reporters uh
were former white house employees in one
shape or another
guys 7 000 people hit the wrong button
yes they did and then all that happened
they retracted their button yes they
were like what am i doing right and they
hit like instead well but i love how
they took the dislike button away and
they're like look we're not going to do
that because it's bad for content
creators we don't want their mental like
health affected by this but they didn't
take away the ability for you to hit the
dislike button and for the content
creators to see it yeah you still see it
on the back end yeah i still see it on
the back end
we want to hide information from you
yeah no we don't want to hurt your
mental health so we want you to deal
with the stain for you privately yeah
yes
when you have the least amount of help
yeah and let's also not forget that big
tech employs when people talk about big
business it's not even close when people
used to [ __ ] about big business whether
it was banks or oil companies
or i'm trying to think of other big
companies that would be an example uh
you know like 18 t companies like that
you know
you would be talking about maybe some of
them did like a 60 40 republican split
yeah
and that would be considered favoritism
and people go out and protest now we
have companies that are far more
powerful than international governing
bodies and the split is not like 60 40.
it's 98 99 for democrats twitter when
you look at the the big tech employees
99
democracy democrats netflix 98
alphabet which is google and youtube 88
oh okay well that's a little microsoft
85 apple 84 amazon 77 facebook 77
that's almost like a vote dump coming in
at three o'clock in the morning almost
after they said they've stopped counting
votes yes just just to be clear well to
be fair they accidentally said that
while they were hitting the dislike
button that's true
of course many of them retracted their
votes i don't know if you guys knew that
yeah yeah
right that well that's a good point
thank you for fact checking they should
have just said please look away while we
do what we're about to do and we'll talk
to you in the morning they did they just
did it with newspapers yes and bristol
boards yes which i don't know where you
get that many bristol boards i haven't
gotten a bristol board since the fourth
grade wow well that's why there's so
many left over to cover up windows right
and keep in mind this is when we talk
about a conspiracy i want you to comment
below on this because i've always
i've always had a low-grade irritation
for conspiracy theorists
because it's like the jesse ventura
thing where they never really come up
with answers they say i'm just asking
questions
i'm just asking what happened about
dollar seven okay but what's the answer
i'm just asking what why don't you wanna
ask questions i am but i want to
eventually come to an answer what i'm
saying is how many people have to be
involved with this to be a conspiracy
but we just give you the numbers of the
employees and of course you have the
ceos
that are included in big tech companies
who give overwhelmingly to democrats you
have the numbers that you see on youtube
you have the numbers that you just saw
on twitter over half of them are fake
and
it's also not far-fetched to think that
they are working with the white house
when publicly
white house officials like gensake not
anymore but once upon a time the press
secretary she was encouraging big tech
to do their bidding for them
our hope is that all major tech
platforms and all major news sources for
that matter be responsible and be
vigilant to ensure the american people
have access to accurate information on
something as significant as covid19 that
certainly includes spotify so this
disclaimer it's a positive step but we
want every platform to continue doing
more to call out misinformation
disinformation we'll also uplifting
accurate information
do you have any idea as to how scary
that is before we even got to the board
of misinformation the ministry of truth
you don't think
that official you don't think that susan
wojcicki you don't think that whether
it's jeff bezos mark zuckerberg at that
point jack dorsey
you don't think that they hear a proxy
the arm of the former vice president of
the united states you don't think they
hear that person saying hey
we really want you to do this
and have a decision to make
you don't think they have her on speed
dial
it's not far-fetched guess what they're
going to say oh well we better listen
because these people can uh tax us more
or regulate us more it's not some random
person this is the proxy of the
president of the united states saying we
really hope that you create
more misinformation targeting and what's
that anyone who questions vaccinations
uh for covid and by that i mean anyone
who questions their efficacy for uh you
know people who are 25 uh 25 and younger
and their fourth booster we really hope
that uh all these other big tech
companies you know uh maybe uh clamp
down on joe rogan we're just saying we
really hope
that you don't allow anyone out there to
say that this was anything other than
the freest and fairest election
doesn't require that many people
to be involved it's her saying all ali
oxen free and bezos and zuckerberg
popping their head out like all right
we really hope that you censor this fake
story about hunter biden's laptop
remember right you just tell people what
they can and can't hear that that's the
problem like in an if and the same
people listening are the people who
plumped up joe biden's twitter followers
to to
by 49 yeah in a perfect world of course
it would be great if we didn't have
disinformation misinformation but
unfortunately we don't live in that
world and the only way to try to get
there is to say hey somebody is in
charge of determining what it is that
never works eventually even if you get
an altruistic person who does it
perfectly the first time it eventually
will devolve into somebody telling you
what is true not telling you what truth
is but have we ever had it like it is
now where everything's in cahoots with
each other in the sense of because we've
never had this many uh
i don't know places where you can have
it they used to have it with i will say
this they had it once upon a time with
legacy media right walter cronkite was
considered my god an actual journalist
yes and then we had this beautiful short
window with the internet where everyone
was able to have a voice yes and that's
how joe during that period when joe
rogan flourished when we grew which then
came to a screeching halt on youtube we
cannot gain new subscribers on our main
channel yeah and by that i mean when
people say well what makes it well 1
100th of the growth that we saw every
single month four or five years one one
hundredth to the day of demonetization
and then it became a national story and
that's why the best thing you can do is
if if you're willing share this because
that's what the youtube algorithm favors
right now and it's an upstream battle
but they used to have that and then they
said oh my gosh we were late to the
party abc cnn cbs so then they said we
need to get on youtube we need to
eliminate independent content i can tell
you this because when i worked at fox
news
there were people there was a legal
department of fox news that removed from
my own channel
my clips of me appearing on fox news
they said we don't want we don't want
anything going on fox news we don't want
any fox news we want people using our
player exclusively i said well this is a
way to reach new people and now
they have tucker carlson and sean
hannity doing end cards yeah sean
hannity if you like this subscribe to
our youtube channel that's the internet
correct
as well yeah whereas they used to fight
it fight it fight it and then they said
okay now we want it to be ours and we
want to get rid of the competition so
that's
it's just a reincarnation of what we
used to have but here's my question too
and this should have been my question of
the day they said the dislike to likes
oh it's just it was just spam it was an
oversight yeah
okay hey 49.5
at minimum of joe biden's followers
were fake it was just an oversight you
didn't have anyone monitoring
the most powerful man in the world's
account
it's just an oversight that's what
happened with us when we had things get
removed on youtube right several times
that were reinstated oh it was just it
was just an oversight
has there ever been an oversight
that has gone
favorably in the other direction
has there ever been an oversight that
has helped for example channel like ours
grow has there ever been an oversight
that takes place or has taken place
during an election that was then changed
i know you're talking about that example
in michigan that's just because they got
caught they got caught
yeah why do the oversights and the
glitches always go one direction
remember those stories about the
oversights of oh too many spam dislikes
on the trump briefings
genuinely can you comment below i want
to if if i'm missing some i would love
to know it
how can they always go in one direction
it's weird
okay
speaking of uh direction
project veritas is
so funny they're in a one-way track we
need to uh admonish me here you need to
admonish me because yesterday i said
admonish if you are
a nerdy uh undesirable employee at one
of the big tech companies and uh you
know a bosomy blonde approaches you
right you're being honey potted and it's
probably project veritas right
yeah and i said they're always sending
women yeah yeah yeah and that's just how
what they do is they send attractive
women and then guys
they drool over themselves and they just
give a bunch of information so i was
wrong and i apologize woman that was a
generalization um
there was a guy this time now this is a
guy who approached the the lead client
partner again alex martinez in twitter
so two guys so project veritas sent in a
guy ah and they still got the keys to
the vault which i'm imagining
i just watched this clip this morning
probably just two strawberry daiquiris
so i was
confused
as to how a guy could get this
information
let's watch the clip people are starting
to leak now like what unfortunately it
would be like you recording oh
honey giving it to like
the new york times
here i decided to go with the twitter
representative here's what he had to say
they got a
corporate security
targeting of types wait wait you can
read it let me see
how to protect yourself
groups like project veritas
mispronounced right now on
uh it's like some group that's trying to
just out the employees
like they're trying to like write notes
with them like this
come on he came out a long time
like this is what's really happening
this is what they're telling us to not
do you're lucky that you met me
organically because i would be
questioning everything about you now to
be fair you're like why is that guy so
you know loose lips yeah uh gay ships we
the the man who was the project veritas
uh investigative reporter in question
was this guy so it is tough yeah well
that's
i love that this guy is like yeah they
warned us about this because we were
talking about it they have got to be
beating their heads against the table
going how do we keep falling for this
these employees are so stupid they just
always get a little bit drunk with
someone they want to have sex with and
they sent a notice out saying be careful
don't go on dates the guy's like yeah it
could be a date like this yeah i'm just
so glad i met you organically yeah you
came up to me weirdly and started asking
me questions about my job yeah at the
purple stallion when we were watching
that movie it was just weird it was just
it just felt so
swipe right
[Laughter]
hector brought aids into this office
[Laughter]
it happened so quickly so hats off to
project very tough but this guy is
basically saying everything that we
already know and again how many examples
do you have to have of people in
positions of authority hey you know what
liberals leftists
do your stings with big tech hey i will
actually fund it
i will fund this this is not a joke i
will fund liberal activists who want to
do stings at big just like project
veritas and if you can come back with
any example
of them saying that we
disproportionately throttle liberals
yeah that facebook or you if you can
find any example undercover of people
who work in these companies
saying they're trying to screw leftists
out of being on their platforms or trans
lgbtqaip
i'll fund the sting operation i will buy
you the camcorder that you duct tape to
your forehead
that's fair
we've never seen it no no we've never
seen it of course not but in the
hearings hirono and the others were
saying of course they target left as
well as right i mean come on there
there's no there's no bias in these
companies right now come on yeah
they're just dangling meat in front of
horny people and getting all the
information they need guys like hey yeah
what can you tell us about uh twitter
censoring people well i'm not allowed to
talk about that here's another frozen
margarita oh well we get rid of
conservatives and i'm a communist the
button on my jeans just opened yeah oh
boy do i have to tell you wow i would be
totally worried about you if i hadn't
met you so wait is that your penis so
casually
that's just like the fly tangs or just
like pianos
uh speaking of censoring and the
disinformation board that we brought up
just now lane just sent me this they're
pausing the disinformation board oh good
yeah there was just just enough too much
just enough backlash just enough time
though for them to spend a hundred
billion dollars on another useless
bureaucratic pile of crap
who do they test these concepts with yes
we're going to call it the
disinformation board or the ministry of
ministry truth i know with somebody
coming up with that right like of course
they're going to come up with that how
do you look at that and go yeah let's
put this person in charge she has a
terrible past yeah that'll be good and
by the way she's the problem with the
country but you know blacks and latinos
are becoming more conservatives just so
you know it's it's suburban white hags
who are the ones who start in the
country we need to build a wall around
pottery barn
[Laughter]
just for a little bit until 25-ish just
send 50 mexicans and a pallet of bricks
to every anthropology and seal them
until 2025. just just for a minute
that's right and then you can come back
out pier one imports yep
yep just uh buy their votes with coal's
cash
it's true that's the demographic it's
suburban women like the person who is in
charge of the board of misinformation
who said we need to make this safer
because women deal with horrible
misogyny online do you have any idea the
kinds of tweets
and private messages that dave gerald
and i get
you guys get private messages oh yeah
mainly from you a lot of dick pics yeah
well that's not exactly what it is it's
someone else's no it's just pictures of
his face
[Music]
[Laughter]
careful you're not allowed to do this on
youtube
oh that's
just hold up hold up no you can't do
that either just hold up like oh it's
like pantomime guns
[Applause]
you can't do this because can i hug
if it's a man yeah so yes yes yes gerald
hug
die
oh
i'm gonna go meet a man in a bar and
tell him about a show what was that the
cave closing in aladdin jesus no that
was from uh independence day all right
so uh this uh
that was
this outfit
too
it was it really was
this man out competing brian stelter for
straightest man on earth at twitter um
also said that twitter isn't profitable
because of the leftist ideological bent
of the business uh which is bad okay but
here's the thing you know i've said that
gay people and trans people often get
away with behavior that would be
completely unacceptable for people who
aren't gay or trans
how fast do you think i would get in
trouble if i just made fun of someone
who was actually special needs for being
special needs
there would be a hit piece on the web
today right but if you say it with a
lisp like this twitter employee
undercover a little bit sloshed it
softens the landing
elon musk is a person he is
whatever i don't think he's a looney
tune he has us he has hospitals awesome
yeah i know that
so he's special we all know that that's
fine
so here no one's gonna say something
crazy
because
don't you also see his piece of why
can't we just all love each other
haven't you seen his other tweets where
he's like i'm like your special needs
you're literally special names
literally though you really are so
i can't even take what you're saying
because
you're special
it's a genius you idiot
he's taking people to space what are you
doing he made rocket ships in the
electric car he's just special needs so
no one says anything right
i mean he's he's a little bit quirky
he's not i am sam
and you're unemployed yeah what a [ __ ]
i want a spacex right now
no one says anything bad on because his
special needs yes you do you all say bad
things about him you literally go on to
say it within the next phrase like so we
shouldn't take anything he says because
he's special but that's the thing with
liberals right you see it and with
leftists he's not using the word
[ __ ] so right people it's not that
offensive they want to make it about
words not about context right i think
saying hey you know what uh that person
is uh is be careful that person is
mentally [ __ ] so uh you know be
aware of it i think that that is less
offensive than someone saying hey that
special needs person is less of a person
yeah which one matters to you context
above content
i don't know anything else to say about
this no i think that's a good way to
about this can i say fairy no no no no
no no no no no no no no he's the truth
fairy well i did
he's no tinkerbell
no he is exactly thinking
he's certainly one of the lost boys they
call him three in the stinker bell
just wait till he rolls up his legs and
yells bangarang
what a [ __ ]
well i think someone needs the boobs
i wish someone's job be taken away but
wow wow oh no yeah yeah that's that's
ill-gotten game that joe oh yeah he's
he'd make a great matron d at applebee's
i mean what do you keep this guy and be
like yeah are you the guy that literally
pulled like the notice up while on a
date saying don't go on dates because
this company could be scat fishing you i
mean how does the ceo or how whoever is
in charge human resources bring him in
when they fire him where do they even
start it's like oh my god is it because
i got drunk on camera no is it because
when i got drunk i revealed their
algorithmic secrets no is it because i
made fun of elon musk for being [ __ ]
no is it because i slept with the
project very tested partner no i just
can you just give me a hint
uh all of them oh that makes sense this
guy's gonna have to not only change his
name and appearance he's going to have
to become straight to get out from under
this he's going to have to change yeah
by the way if anybody's going to keep
your secrets catty gay guy
it's like it's like currency for those
people
oh he's just it's over sorry buddy that
was a really bad idea wow yeah if i
could if i could crypto mine gay rumors
they're going to be no people going on
dates at all in silicon valley right for
a little while it's just going to be
very real no swipe rights at all there's
one conservative gay guy like what the
[ __ ]
yeah you and i could be confetti coin
billionaires
[Laughter]
it's just the doge dog with eye shadow
yeah
is that a dog is it a fox it's a dog
it's what is a shibu something you know
it's worthless
it's almost worthless it's a net loss
that's what it is no it's still got some
value it's uh you're working till 72.
yeah if you've got a lot of them and i
mean a lot
you may have some dollars
the actual like fake chocolate dollars
are worth more that's those coins you
get those are good all right okay so
there you go i don't have much more to
add to project very what's going on
there with project veritas we've already
known this to be true i'm just surprised
as to it's just how brazen they are they
don't fear accountability they really
don't i mean if i have someone come up
after one of our shows and tell me that
i have nice hair i'm like what are you
trying what are you trying to get from
me
[Applause]
look at them a little leery yeah exactly
i'll stop saying that yeah
i don't know if you say you have to
reach out and touch it oh
i can't help it
[Laughter]
gross something we all know you want to
reach out in all right speaking of which
we're going to go to mug club here
because there's no way we can
i am actually looking forward to
watching this because alone you guys
know exactly oh which by the way reminds
me hey johnny boy or uh maximus uh-huh
this is not a joke i forgot to bring it
in in my office desk in the center
drawer
is where all of my she-hulk cards are
if you could grab them they're laminated
and they're in perfect mint condition
why would they be laminated well i'll
explain that behind uh the mug club so
we are going to
watch if you're watching our mug club
lotto.com club they will bring in those
cards that's not that's a real thing
it's 100 real we're going to watch the
uh yeah but we have a teaser here right
of the uh no we um
we're not going to do it oh that's right
because we'll get hit with a copyright
thing okay we're going to watch the new
she-hulk trailer yeah which is also i
mean the working title was lesser hulk
uh piss off youtube
[Music]
you